mathieu madénian la dernière fois que
vous êtes venus on a joué l'un contre
l'autre au jeu de la poisse avant
d'accueillir camille combal avec
d'ailleurs une parodie encore de mokhtar
aujourd'hui j'ai perdu trois fois la
dernière fois regarder les images vous
vous apporter deux boissons il y en a
une des gueux et une des listes 1 2 3
vous avez deux jeunes filles de dos il y
en a eu qui viendra vous faire un smack
et la celle que vous aurez choisi
celle que vous n'aurez pas choisi me
fera un smack à moi moi je dis que c'est
celle qui est à ma droite que vous
prenez ouais
applause agency et moi et moi
alors attention vous ne les touchez pas
il y en a en fait on va jouer les durs
vous soigner ça ne vous me montrez et
vous vous le cas c'est sur la tranche
fois rim essence 1 2 3
je vais m'en vais je vais demander à
norman de prendre ma revanche normal et
humain digne on venait avec moi vous
êtes mois normal et mathieu alors c'est
très simple première épreuve la première
épreuve
elle est là je vous le dis 2e derrière
koh lanta qui reprend derrière ces
coupes elle il y a un gros ver blanc à
manger et soul autres coupes l'ol il y à
un délicieux verre ainsi un bonbon voilà
un verre voilà un bonbon à la fraise
alors allez-y honneur à norman il
choisit je kiffe ce jeu c'est vraiment
super ouais t'as carrière commence il
est vivant le vert je sais pas moi c'est
pas moi qui fais les coupes et les voilà
bah vous allez au dégivrage et le bon
contre pour moi c'est l'équipe aussi
c'est koh lanta demain
vous allez voir gens-là et manger plein
c'est pas possible ça qui dépassa savez
seriez vous allez voir quand vous avez
croqué il va lâcher comme un petit truc
impossible mais c'est rien allez dis que
j'ai mis très vite
oh non c'est bon
vingt sièges actuels deuxième duel
je leur dis à demain à fait minime à 6 g
collomb deuxième duel attention derrière
une des boîtes il y à un serpent oh non
non non fort était là je croyais que je
veux je peux vraiment des fire non mais
vous inquiétez pas venez de mon côté non
dans une des boîtes il ya un serpent et
on en est dans l'autre il y a un bon ac
reçoit en plastique d'accord non est
jeune il va alors ça non
choisissez c'est bon non mais juste vous
touchez un peu le serpent pour la faire
aller vous promener clé de boîte à
tintin avec la boîte zf 10 à la jeunesse
féret quel bois elle inquiète a les
mains jointes celles là voyez ça la mode
et la [ __ ] je ne la mets ici mais je
sais et c'est le vrai ou pas
c'est donc normal qu'on prend tout
normalement quand bobby total c'est que
c'est un peuple attendait regarde c'est
peut-être pas sûr qu'il y soit allé y
regarder il est là il est vraiment
dégueulasse carrière à sa garde et c'est
du serpent d'eau douce cela éviterait
dussart sur la tête sur la tête bon
allez on y va j'ai toujours j'ai
toujours un serpent sur bois l'instant
je me débrouillais plus costaud on va
passer au 4ème duel tout de suite hier
dans trois jeunes mais on va pas le
faire parce que il ya il y a deux
personnes ici vous trouverez le noir il
est à deux personnes
jonah hill ces deux personnes paru ces
deux personnes il y en a un qui est
champion de karaté et l'autre il n'a
jamais fait de karaté de sa vie d'accord
l'un s'appelle brian et l'autre
s'appelle thibault s'appelle brian
landes youssou ndour vous devez appeler
au hasard brian ou thibault il devra
vous mettre un coup de pied de karaté
c'est là ça a cassé un jeu plutôt sympa
et seaway donc pas sur celui qui n'a
jamais fait de karaté êtes tranquille
qu'il peut tenter brian ou tivo qui tu
veux je commence mes parents j'ai pas
mal de chance alain normalement il ya un
piège
non mais appeler brian ou thibault bryan
bryan [ __ ]
alors brian juste petite question est-ce
que vous avez déjà fait si vous avez
déjà fait du karaté
oui j'ai déjà fait auparavant quand
j'étais petit et vous jamais jamais
cette tombe adenyo alors tous à quelque
chose quand même
oui merci anne elle coûte 100 m dans les
robes web à la voile a battu vous allez
vous mettre la haye vous à la fin ça
ferme et et mettez-vous là je vais
tomber sur le site aurait fait gaffe
quand même un voile avait battu son ami
tu es un baulois web j'adore continue je
kif à dernier un dernier alors foiré
mais bon dieu merci
les avengers entre dénaturer il ya
toujours la chance il a toujours de la
chance à l'autre